right now you have three different
spectrums I'm seeing in terms of how
people feel about this movie you have
people who are like what the weird
creaks talking about I love this movie
then there are people who go two-thirds
of it are good that finale is kind of a
letdown and then you got people people
on the spectrum oh man what a
disappointment
yeah so you got three pretty much
different opinions and those tend to be
the three and I'm on that side hello
there reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey we're gonna talk about a
little I mean I - have another nutty
movie called glass highly-anticipated
so this is actually gonna be sort of
podcast format there's a variety of
reasons why I mean we decided to a
little set in case people decide will
watch us for however [ __ ] long we
talk today because if I happen to be
watching I should do my hair like glass
let's use curly here yeah you just got
to get that part going on the one side I
mean if you guys are actually podcasting
this you can't see what I'm doing yeah
yeah there's gonna be a spoiler talk
first off the reason or just hopping
into spoiler is be a man I'm gonna so
distracted by my hair it's gonna be a
spoiler talk because after the movie was
done I was like I have no clue how to
communicate this my my I've never felt
so passionate about an M night Shyamalan
movie before never like I I adore the
hell out of on break I love that movie
great this movie elicited some other
kind of passion not see coming I didn't
and and I figured that
the only way to really communicate my
thoughts on this would be to just hop
into a spoiler and the reason we're
doing podcast format is because I don't
really want to is this January time it's
not like you make money in January and
YouTube with your videos you put about
that every youtuber is thinking about it
they're just not talking about it but
that's what almost every youtuber is
they get about and I'm all and also
Universal is not overly friendly that's
honestly the main reason is literally
like for for Halloween which is a
universal produced Blum House venture
Universal they're very very I know angry
show put out a thing about Lionsgate
recently he taught me briefly touched on
Universal but Universal especially if I
if we even use just footage with no
audio usually that's the trick to kind
of get away with things for you guys who
are aspiring youtubers well and look at
fair use technically if you're using
visual aids to help with commentary
that's legal yeah yes and it's like
we're not showing the clips we're not
showing the trailers and but no audio at
all but sometimes just a visual aid gets
the video demonetized
so like putting together the halloween
spoiler review where it took about 45
minutes to shoot ever took me about two
to three hours to edit down and then you
know whatever time it took to make the
[ __ ] thumbnail and then you make yeah
I'm like oh man it's demotivating to
wanna like cut up a video together so
and that was a positive so if you guys
just want to walk around if you want to
clean if you want to do whatever to you
just listen like I do with a lot of
these longer videos is I just listen I
don't really sit down and watch if you
want to watch look at my weird thing my
hair just now go for it but yeah let's
talk about glass spoiler talk if you
haven't seen it that's been your warning
it's gonna be all spoilers from here on
out and
I don't really have a guide I'm just
gonna really go off my feelings here I
did write down some notes on my phone
for myself last night but before going
into this I think that there are three
well there's several ways you can kind
of rank this movie that we're hitting me
about halfway through the movie one way
is to go as a January movie it's pretty
good like for a January movie it's not
it's not say malicious yeah it's trying
to do a lot of things yeah it's it's
definitely like one of the better
January films and it's a distinct movie
that feels like it was authored by like
a filmmaker of the certain caliber yes
and it's not it's not M night Shyamalan
worst movie I'm not gonna say that it's
not his worst film so that might earn
you some brownie points you know just
because sure he was on a high note with
the visit being good split being a major
success and in this movie which is so
much hype yeah having so much hype but
it's not his worst film and then there's
the the concept of it is the follow-up
to both unbreakable and split in that
department
I find it exceptionally disappointing
because okay I I think that there are
people who really are gonna be strong
defenders of this movie and as much as I
love going on screen jockeys movie
fights I truthfully hate arguing with
people in real life okay like I know how
to respectfully disagree with someone I
do I know how to disagree with an
individual the internet doesn't usually
screw you you're an [ __ ] hey you die
yourself here's why this movie is great
you know I don't know anyone like that
in real life will disagree okay but I
don't um I don't disagree with people
like in a hateful way so I'm not gonna
cuz I know we have some disagreements on
some areas with this movie seems like
generally there's some areas that we see
eye to eye on I feel like we ultimately
feel similarly
in the piece about passionate about I
think are very different but a lot of
our points will probably align yeah well
I saw that it had a forty percent on
Rotten Tomatoes I mean that's like
thirty five like from the critics right
and I I didn't really let that affect me
because I was like movies you and I have
both seen that got terrible reviews and
then we watch it and then we both are
like they're shallow movies that people
just hate with a passion
yeah well I'm like I don't like it
looking over a lot of the early capsule
reviews anyway it seemed like even like
positive negative it seemed like it was
divisive and like everybody was kind of
picking apart different elements and
that to me going in was still kind of
exciting because I was like I may not
get something guaranteed to be great but
I'm getting something that's guaranteed
to at least be kind of fascinating or
interesting or something see I got a I
got a say like even after watching it I
am excited to talk about it yeah not
because I'm here and I'm going I can't
wait to rip this movie a new one which I
feel like I'm probably going to I I'm
excited because this is evidently a
divisive film it's not like this film
sits at a solid 50 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes when the movie was done we I
took strong note of a giant packed IMAX
experience that zero people play no not
even a single nobody tried to start the
moment I think where I could sense we
were all wondering yeah but no I was
like oh maybe I'm not alone on this
maybe maybe this is because I thought
okay maybe critics hate it but this
would be a crowd-pleaser you know and I
haven't heard any actual reviews what I
did was I kind of I went through the
capsules and then I saw like on screen
juggie news for example I started the
review of glass and I just heard
I like it and I stopped it like I didn't
actually finish it and I did it with a
lot of people on mine yes I like it
leave it at that I don't hear any
details I feel like that's the best time
for like a thumb up thumb down stock
since watching it I have I still haven't
hurt anyone's review so I don't want
anyone to like influence my opinion
maybe I'll listen to some people's
reviews be like oh wait a minute good
point yeah I didn't see it that way the
thing is I don't feel like that's gonna
happen there are certain movies that I
just really don't like and then I look
back on it and I go you know what though
I really dug that film actually or it's
like Dark Knight Rises for example was
that kind of movie were it it didn't
give me what I expected
and it's got some evident flaws or
difficulties or something yeah it's not
quite nailing it the way the Dark Knight
did for example yeah then I but then
when I watch it again or looking back on
just looking back on it I started to
really appreciate it yeah I really like
that movie despite some of the flaws and
and thus I'm not like letdown yeah yeah
you know glass kind of just upsets me
more I talk about it the more I break it
down the more the more annoyed I get
with this movie you see cuz I think from
a standalone movie perspective I don't
even think in that department it's all
that good of a movie I think technically
speaking it's its paces weird its
structure is poorly done I think its
dialogue I think the characters become
so much plot devices III think that the
some of the performances are like I
actually know what the performances are
good performances yeah good there are
times when I think the director M night
Shyamalan makes choices that doesn't
help the performances in the long run he
doesn't limit himself like I think
that's a big issue
Shyamalan has this obsession with the
theme of belief if you look at all like
unbreakable unbreakable is David Dunne
story of him
having to go through you know having to
believe in himself so I'm gonna lift
those weights guard those weight you
know that's like the power of the mind
belief split similar thing of what if
you can put it like that sure deals with
the psychological aspect of di D but
then it's also about what if you
believed it so much it could change your
body chemistry you can come and then you
look at his other movies after earth
yeah signs with the whole arc with Mel
Gibson's character inside all about
faith I don't really remember the
village I don't know if I feel like
there's something we believe I'm well I
don't know lay the water know there's
something about belief from their buddy
wheels a lot in this theme of belief I
mean the village is all about a major
deception you know yes and the belief
that comes out of that and the and also
as we go into this I was thinking about
it I'm like a part of what makes is his
twist the good twist of Charlotte
effective is your belief in what's being
portrayed on screen first
for example six cents you believe you're
just watching a guy who's playing child
psychiatrist to a kid who sees dead
people you believe that so when the
twist comes it's there the whole time
glass and I remind me to bring this
point back up again later this and I
thought about it I was like not glass
I'm breakable unbreakable this is why I
had such issue with Sarah Paulsen's
character and her twist reveal in this
movie because if you look at how the
movie unbreakable handled it yeah that's
how I thought they should have done it
where glass is really the bad guy of
unbreakable right he's really the baddie
but in a very interesting way yes but
that's not revealed till the very end in
its twists moments similar what they do
is Sarah Paulson here the thing is I I
had a moment or two an unbreakable when
I first saw like he kind of seems like a
suspicious guy and over the course of
the film till its final reveal you get
to a point of believing that he is
really the support and aid to help David
Dunn become who he needs to be their
friendship is ten exactly so when that
twist comes it's whoa what the [ __ ]
you know like that's what makes it so
effective okay I don't want to go too
much into town but I'm gonna bring up
some of those key points later this
movie I thought I just on a standalone
level had just so many plot holes
illogical character choices it seemed
like it if thought it was this very
nuanced commentary when I was it didn't
feel lived in to me we're we're a split
and unbreakable feel like it's themes
and commentary are lived in through its
portrayal of the characters because as a
standalone movie I don't really like it
as an unbreakable and split follow-up I
hate it that's the difference it was two
different feelings in yeah the neat
thing for me is I feel like whenever we
do these reviews typically you're very
good at reviewing the the previous stuff
and coming in and usually I like to do
the yang to that and kind of come in
with fresh eyes it's been a while since
I've seen split and unbreakable so to me
this was more of a standalone experience
and yeah as a standalone experience
coming from that perspective it still
has so many ways in which it doesn't
hold up and it doesn't quite stick so
many of the landings that's trying for
and one of the big things I've realized
more and more as I've thought about it
is that is the biggest missing element
is this movie doesn't feel like it has a
protagonist it just has a bunch of
characters in one place that we kind of
look at from time to time while people
talk about them and they talk about
another and nobody like there are a
couple POV shots but you never really
feel like you get inside the head of
David Dunn or Elijah price or Kevin Crum
in this movie they're just these kind of
objects on screen even Sarah Paulson if
she's the protagonist isn't even really
a protagonist everybody checks out for a
long time the person on screen the most
is James McAvoy just oscillating through
personalities you know over and over oh
man do I have some issues with how that
was hammering we're gonna go all over
the place on I know it because like
there I thought this move is so
problematic yeah but you have a good
that's that's the pretty much the the
the core of the issue with the movie is
it doesn't know it's a point of view it
doesn't know its perspective it misses
an opportunity to give you an emotional
avatar to invest in or somebody to be on
this journey with so now we're just kind
of peering into a lab you know yeah it
feels like M night Shyamalan made a
fanfiction follow up is because it is
unruly in the way that a fanfiction can
be it's like ah but but but then this
happened you know like I feel the
outline and I like a lot of the ideas I
do and there are are there sequences
that are cool yeah there's some cool
sick like I love that sha when elijah is
wheeling and then the other basement
kevin cigars behind him great shot and a
great moment because you see the emotion
in Elijah's face and the action behind
him and it creates something that's
actually new on this is some of Sam
Jackson's lines are awful awfully
written but his performance saves so
much of that of those lines like he is
amazing he's the best part of this whole
movie it does when he finally comes into
the plot he he does a lot for this he
elevates the [ __ ] out of this media like
there does there were times I was sold
I might start liking this movie because
of him but it never really got me to
that department it never swung me that
direction yeah the whole movie for me
was a back and forth between like okay
this is cool I'm getting engaged maybe
it's taken off could be taken off now
and I see it I see it oh yeah
like if parties just review it as a
standalone I I do think that it's poorly
read into especially its dialog like
Shyamalan is not exactly known to be
subtle he tends to be a little preachy
but especially here it's so ham-fisted
like I said it not lived in which has a
follow-up film very disappointing
because those those predecessors are
very much lived in movies that get these
points across and have perspectives it's
like unbreakable is about David Dunn
being thrown into the perspective of the
world of glass and slit is the
perspective of of Kevin and then in this
movie it's like okay it's it starts off
with this
fast pacing like I'll tell you I was
never bored
how were you bored I was never I was
never actually bored during this movie
there were times where I was sitting
there going ok let's pick it up or or I
would say to myself this scene I would
have chosen a slightly different tone
because the way this movie is
progressing it feels like it's starting
to plod because it thinks it's doing
something a lot more important than it's
actually doing yes there are times when
I was a little bit like but but I was
never just like disengaged you know like
yeah when I was out of it I was still
thinking about it you know fair yeah
that's fair I don't know how to describe
what that feeling is but I think from
the very beginning I started to see its
flaws as a follow-up because I think
this movie does a lot that kind of
abuses don't look into the twist and
everything but I think it does a lot
that abuses the a lot of moments that
were very earned in the first
oh the predecessors oh yeah this this
movie has a major problem earning its
moments across the board yeah and then
we're previous ones earned them really
well for the most part and then
repeating moments from the predecessors
and just throwing it in here because
that was just a thing that happens yeah
I really felt like he got high on on the
success of split and rushed he he rushed
this one and and you know the you you
brought that up about how his original
cut was like three and a half hours show
and it feels like the combination of you
should have spent more time on your
script to really make this as good as
you think it is and also let's smooth
this out yeah well when it starts off
already with you know James McAvoy's
Kevin from Kevin crumb and Wendell crud
he has the girls it was like okay
there's no real build-up to this there's
no real tension it's just what he's
doing up maybe I can just get on board
with this but it's moving kind of just
so fast it's catching up what David done
and Kevin crumb was moving so fast where
if you look at him breakable and split
they do such a good job and build-up and
tension and reeling you in where this
movie seems to have a lot of these sound
designs and music cues of a horror movie
but I don't feel any suspense or
attention because it's just happening so
quickly that I'm like okay you know
alright oh there's the thing work
and kidnaps girls the word of that
moment in split where he first does it
is effective that introduction is
powerful it's is it's scary then here
it's like oh it said of three now he's
got four he's doing this thing it was
like Kevin's back to his old trick I
wake not into Kanye now isn't Drake haha
that's funny right remember that and and
like I was excited when I saw you know
David Dunn's kid wasn't here yeah and
that catch up I was sort of appreciating
there were times when it Philip felt a
little silly and other times where I
thought it felt really nice but I like
the general gist that they're working
together and he's his guy in the chair
and stuff like that I thought that was
really sweet actually like I'm all for
defying expectations I'm all for that
I just I think that expectations though
were especially laid out by M night
Shyamalan himself he's tweeting about it
constantly
that's that's the that's like the issue
I have with what we expected like I'm
not even going to go to the marketing of
how this film made it look like it's
David Dunn versus Kevin the show you
know like I'm not even to go to that I'm
gonna talk about strictly M night's
expectation he does everyone wanted a
follow up to the David Dunn movie
unbreakable that's David Dunn's movie
that's not glasses movie right like I
love the idea of do yet the David Dunn
movie the the Kevin Crowe movie and then
you have the glass but I thought that's
cool yeah you Center it right a great
idea concepts cool and then it's fitting
for the mastermind to be the centerpiece
right ending chapter David Dunn is
barely a thing in this movie about that
is for as much as this movie goes into
comic book Laura and and meta stuff I'm
like so you know in a roundabout way
without winking at the camera and
acknowledging it you've kind of shown us
that it's it's the hero's kind of the
least interesting character I guess
because this movie just forgets about
him forever it does most of the Tura
movie that [ __ ] keeps the most you
see that's what I mean it's like because
of its lack of perspective and point of
view improper
he's proper mood building in this film
whenever they I'm breakable when they go
into comic stuff when glass starts
talking about this comic book [ __ ] in
that movie it's like this is kind of
cheesy but David does reaction of that
was like but then as it's building in
its moods going you believe the fantasy
you believe the poetry you believe it
and then David being averse to it at
first helps us because that's our
reaction and then in here you know what
a big issue I have on just a technical
scale there's the there's a very poetic
superhero kind of romanticizing version
with with the with unbreakable and
there's a very specific tone in mood and
and then split has this this thriller
that has that explores a psychological
aspect so the breakables is commentary
on superheroes and then split is the
this like yeah sure on diid but also
it's a it's a psychological exploration
what it plays of the horror of the
villainy of a super yeah and you know
and then in this movie instead of
finding his own unique tone he just kind
of tries meshing it and it doesn't work
it does it so that when when glass
starts spouting off like comic books
yeah you're like this feels kind of dumb
it doesn't feel lived in it feels it
feels good night Shyamalan giving Sam
Hill Jackson words to say now well yeah
the big issue I have with the comic book
aspects of this movie overall it's like
I don't mind that Elijah's doing it I
kind of had an issue that everybody
started to everybody but but more than
that it was that so much of that I could
just feel like yeah there's Sam Jackson
and he's definitely delivering the words
but I just feel like M night Shyamalan
is now talking to me where is that felt
there's so much in this movie that feels
like it's just M night and I feel like a
few more passes on the script could have
helped the characters feel more like
characters instead you know it's lack of
being lived in like I'm gonna keep yet
I'm probably gonna keep saying that a
lot cuz that's the core issue with this
film is it's not lived in anymore and
back to the expectations right split
comes out we have no idea that this is
in the same
I'm glass universe right a split comes
out and then what does he do he throws
David Dunn at the end of the movie not
gloss David Dunn and then what starts
happening when he starts talking about
this
yeah Kevin was originally of the villain
and unbreakable but I couldn't fit him
in so instead I made his own standalone
movie that way they could go up against
each other so you know what that
expectation of wanting to see them go
against each other wasn't the audience's
fault yeah that is M night Shyamalan
fault for wanting that and him not
properly delivering that like do do some
weird things that we didn't see that we
didn't expect do some things that are
unique you know [ __ ] build this
I don't care do that but you got it I
really felt like as an audience member
that was so unbelievably lackluster like
they start fighting in the first five
minutes like the first act they start
fighting each other like literally when
their break in act two is at the end of
their fight and then they have the final
fight and by that point I kind of forgot
David Dunn's in this movie yeah he takes
such a backseat and I'm like what's the
hype with the unbreakable final follow
finally following up if you're not even
gonna what's with all the commentary on
on the superhero genre when you seem to
not give a [ __ ] about your one actual
hero oh yes problem about this movies
the more I think about every aspect of
it the more I'm like I get what could
have worked and I see how it just was a
total mess in execution because in a
sense I'm like okay it kind of seems
like David Donna's Act one Kevin is Act
two glasses Act three but even still
that structure fails itself because you
have an ensemble that never gets a
chance to truly be in ensemble and to
develop it's like they hinted these
things Kevin and David Dunn are like
across the hall from each other and they
hinted these ideas they all know about
each other they all have opinions about
each other and they could have done
interesting stuff about that and they
just never really touched it at all so
by the time that they actually fight it
is underwhelming because you're like a
the fight isn't that cool and B it
really upset me
yeah it really upset me and you know
we're like we're gonna hop around I'm
gonna go and I had an actual thought in
my head where I went [ __ ] you to like
the market and I've never had that with
any M night Shyamalan movie rarely do I
have that with a movie but when they get
shot thank you when they get KITT when
they die yeah I'm all for them dying in
this movie like the concept of Oakley
I'm wrapped up that trilogy but the way
they tie that has nothing to do with the
conflict between them that build up
between Oh Kevin and David are gonna go
up against each other and they die in
such this like emotionless way to have
some twists reveal about shamrock gang
you know
yeah the humanity in order to preserve
ourselves has to either convince these
people that they're crazy or eliminate
them entirely which again is a good idea
to play with in this scenario it's a new
kind of take on some x-men [ __ ] yeah at
the same time again just the movie
doesn't really earn it and it starts to
feel random the way everything comes out
was because he paused three twists on
top of each other
wellyes twist after twist after twist
and literally the last like third like
30 minutes of this movie it's just a
bunch of twists and I'm really starting
to wonder if all the stuff that came out
of that original cut was probably
character moments probably a lot of
David does that stuff and I'm wondering
if maybe that's why Bruce Willis isn't
really behind this movie because maybe a
lot of his scenes got cut or something
it feels that way because David Dunn's
arc it like I I really did not this is
our cut he begins to believe again
because Shyamalan retreads that same
belief territory that's why I started
talking about this because it's like did
you keek I think you could do I'm all
for him doing like five more movies
where the theme is belief it's just if
it's not lived in through the characters
or not proper character story I don't
care for it because I'm like he just
went through the same arc he had in
freaking unbreakable but we just did it
in 10 minutes as opposed to two hours
now like when when Sarah Paulsen is
interviewing them
i I'm actually for the idea I'm for that
idea of a psychiatrist or psychologist
who's like these people are a Connick
these people are crazy they have these
delusions and I know that the ultimate
reveals that says that's not what she
ultimately believes but for that twist
to have an emotional weight I can't be
sitting there in the audience going with
this woman dumb is stupid what why
aren't why are there's so many things
being brought up like all that dumb
justification those those bullets and
that shotgun were old like away what he
was shot
or how about bring up out David Dunn's
medical history he's never been sick how
about he had no scratch on him what he
just bumped his head on the like have a
real debate where cuz in that moment for
that to be effective I have to be as an
audience member going are they actually
crazy like I have to question and maybe
they're not maybe I ultimately don't
believe it but I personally I'm like we
are spending so much time on this debate
so we can do some psychological element
with these characters where ultimately
as an audience I'm like I saw two movies
are these guys I know that they're not
crazy and the fact that they're not
addressing so many other things that
they could be addressing if they're not
having an actual debate it's just her
making like we're just like being able
to climb my walls you know people who
rock climb oh it was dumb to me yeah I I
don't know I get it I like the concept
of that quite a bit and actually I think
that's one of the things the movie does
sometimes succeed at for me personally
there were times where I was sitting
there going oh I didn't expect this and
I'm intrigued by it I don't I I had that
reaction I was like I don't expect them
to just be normal and you know out of
their minds but I like that we're going
there and I like some of the ways
they're trying to explore that and I
liked what the actors each did with that
as they're each becoming convinced
except for obviously Sam Jackson is kind
of never convinced of that but yeah I
mean ultimately it's not
smart enough to truly drive home all of
the things that we've seen because yeah
when he's crawling on the ceiling I mean
you know that's a bit hard to explain
away and I'm forgiving of stuff like
that I was forgiving at the time even
but me ultimately it's one of those
things that there are other movies that
don't do that same thing but like there
are certain movies where the twist is
like oh it's all in the main character's
head and they're a split personality
where that's like a cheap gimmick
because they don't really bother to walk
around inside of it whereas there are
certain other movies that really earned
that twist we've seen a thousand times
by walking around in and making it feel
like you've said multiple times lived in
by earning it and I feel like in that
department for this movie it only gets
about halfway
they had me one room the glass is half
full I love a good pun but I do not
scares up money at the box clever I just
thought there was so much time dedicated
to it and I never the movie never had me
going and I didn't think like for David
to question himself
I couldn't get into it what you guys we
got to see them having a personal moment
about that like we got to see them
struggling with it and really unpack
exactly we don't like that debate is so
poorly written I thought like the actual
scene teas and the bake trailers of
where they're all three sitting around
Sarah Paulson like if David was bringing
up hey I've never been sick do you see
that once in my medical history I've
never been hurt I do this I do this and
she's like able to logically say [ __ ]
that could actually explain that away
then I would have then I would have had
me going a little bit but the thing with
Sarah Paulsen's character is that from
the very second she showed up I was like
nah she's probably not a good person
because of the fact that they're all
[ __ ] waiting outside of Kevin's
Factory like ready all of them and it
just had me going I just kept kept going
back to that moment as I was watching
the film going wait a minute
why well before the reveal of their
shamrock people and that Jesus not with
the cops I was like were they all just
waiting there when would like why
weren't they all trying to get the four
girls who were kidnapped they're talking
about she was saying David would have
you know been arrested and blamed for
that girl's injuries and I'm like well
why the [ __ ] were you guys just chilling
outside how'd you know to be exactly
there that they would [ __ ] fall out
of the damn window and land right there
that is they of course they keep tabs on
them when they do the whole reveal of
their shadowy organization but like yeah
they must know who they know that's my
point though is before that reveal has
happened the reveal is not effective to
me because of the fact that I was
already questioning so much of the plot
holes like you know the girls run out
though and they're causing such a ruckus
and that's a kind of a long fight so by
the time they get outside I was sort of
like oh well maybe one of them found a
phone or something and they called
somebody they found a person and and
someone showed up or maybe somebody
heard the commotion like it's not a nice
party for me that's a stretch honestly
like I can read school that you got
there with that for me I just took it as
but they were just they were literally
just chilling outside waiting for them
to come out like both of them to come
out because like I said I'm going back
to the idea of what makes his twist
effective is that you believe it you
believe the journey and then the oh [ __ ]
that's not what I thought
whereas this whole movie had me going I
don't like the debates at Sarah
Paulsen's bringing up
I like the idea on paper but this movie
across the board is I like the idea I
don't like the execution yes that's it
yeah because the entire execution of
Sarah Paulsen's character was like damn
she's really giving it her all Sarah
Paulson but I don't I don't I don't
believe for one second because I keep
pokey I keep as an audience member to
keep poking holes in everything she's
saying because characters aren't
bringing up stuff and she has weird
justifications for how they were able to
survive certain things certain elements
you know what I mean and then from the
first up for some reason that moment to
me when they first showed up shamrock
people before the reveal
they were Sham repute that that the
audience is supposed to go the audience
as if you were supposed to go those are
police and she's the doctor with them
because they're here to save those girls
just now I don't like why why were they
just chilling out there then it seemed
like they were literally waiting for
them specific I don't know I just didn't
wasn't it wasn't for me that moment
which happened just got out one moment
just had me question her the entire time
and I feel like for sham want to have a
big reveal like that cuz he feel like he
really designed his movie to have that
reveal as opposed to giving us the movie
we just kind of wanted I mean I feel
like that could have been an aspect of
the movie we wanted it just it
prioritized that instead yeah you know
it has priorities all in the wrong
places
and and for me too I hate the the ending
of the three characters the three
supports who for summary like I have an
issue with the way the characters are
written here glasses mom I I get that
she has always been really supportive
and was seen in a breakable that she's
had to take care of her child who's
always been mistreated and was born a
certain way I could have used a little a
little just a tie a hint of some inner
conflict that your son is also a master
your son murdered like over a thousand
[ __ ] people like where's that little
nugget you know to make this a little
bit compelling on you Taylor joy I I
respected wedged into this movie she's
wedged in it and I hate what they did
with her character from a psychological
perspective I like it since what she's
trying to [ __ ] kill him shoot
rightfully so because the guy is insane
he abducted her a murdered is eight two
of her friends you know like I and her
art of going I'm gonna go okay with
introducing that she put her uncle away
and that principal keeps specifying
foster family he didn't you know and all
right cool I'm glad you're there but the
fact that she becomes insanely
sympathetic for for Kevin crumb in this
movie
and they keep ham fisting home we were
both abused and that's why I'm like one
part of me made me go well I'm sure your
uncle who assaulted you raped you all
all these years was probably abused too
why I have no sympathy for him but you
have sympathy for dude who abducts
several little girls and kills them and
sort of a grossly unearned piece of this
movie their nose off ugly and there's a
kernel of something inside of it that I
want to feel like is kind of benevolent
and it just that's one of the most like
poorly handled in a way that's kind of
offensive things about this movie yes
I'm like I'm all for the idea that you
know okay this guy's got a bunch of
different personalities and the true
person that this guy is is just scared
and [ __ ] up and alone and maybe she
can see that amid the spectrum but the
fact that yeah just like the history of
split just completely goes out the
window yeah like I would have liked that
if it was like some kind of conflict for
her where it's like well clearly I can
neutralize this guy and that's an
important thing to have happen this is
weird and scary but also I realize what
I'm doing but yeah at the end it sort of
seems like do these are they just like
this she calms the beast down what like
in and of itself I get that thing
because the whole like you're pure and
and you're not trying clearly you're not
trying to hurt Kevin like and and we all
exist for Kevin like that little nugget
I'm like okay but [ __ ] everything
around it is no I mean I hate the idea
of it in some ways to me it kind of I
think Shyamalan what he's going for is
that our traumas can actually make us
that more powerful I think that's what
he's going for yeah your trauma doesn't
make you a mistake or or a broken thing
necessarily yeah you can make
extraordinary things out of trauma if
you know how to do that but I I felt
that it read it a little offensive and a
little horrified on abuse in some ways
again like this I feel like of all the
movies this one needed the most tender
loving care from an inch
and an empathetic standpoint because not
only is that stuff just in in essential
to making the choices okay
yeah but it's also essential to making
it an engaging gripping moving move and
also you know like going back to just as
a standalone movie of how stupid things
happen there seems like to be literally
no security guards in this place that
had a lot lately I'm like yeah like the
guards in this movie are like caretakers
are pretty dumb pretty dumb they're very
dumb like and it all falls hand in hand
with abusing things from the past like I
think that moment where James McAvoy is
doing the most stereotypical like you
see in split let's talk about abusing
things that came from the past not not
like this is an abusive movie in that
area I'm talking about just not feeling
the moment of what made the things in
the past movie work in split whenever
James McAvoy hop between characters he
felt like he was a different person and
in this movie some people are loving his
performance and I'm glad you do I
personally thought it was very
cartoonish I thought when do you have
that moment where I think gay guy who is
attending to him oh oh oh oh yeah the
orderly the orderly who just keeps
flashing as like what are you doing
first off do you do why are you just
whatever you do ain't gonna make a
difference
stop flushing well that again that's
that's another poorly handled moment Roz
like okay I get it you're horrified but
like engrossed cuz you've probably never
seen something quite like this before
and it it the way it blocks that scene
is pretty de it's dumb and it's like
James McAvoy is now just doing em like
the most stereotypical caricatures it's
not they're not characters anymore that
he's portraying they're just caricatures
well it's yeah it reminded me of that
game we used to play an improv were you
know think about become a new character
yeah and the thing is I think James
McAvoy does incredible work in this
movie and I think
M night Shyamalan the director didn't
help him because I feel like that me
aspect is a Shyamalan problem because he
needed to know where not to indulge
because the thing about the
personalities and the oscillations
between them is that that works and is
so engaging when it is in doses and this
movie indulges hardest on that specific
elements yeah every time you see Kevin
he's like eight different people and
you're like we get it it's impressive
and it's also hurting this movie because
you're not limiting yourself or
finessing it in them the rest of the
film it's like obnoxiously
self-indulgent in that department
because in that moment it really felt
like I was watching like an improv show
yeah it felt like he read that
completely oh we didn't yeah well let's
just put all I don't know were the names
of it but it was literally like him
going hi I'm Hank I'm a cowboy Mexican
that was going on these are people these
are for the most because every single
time there was a new character he was he
would do stereotypical accent
introduction of name what their
profession is or something like that you
know it's they just weren't people
anymore man they weren't people one even
yeah and the writing the way that they
some of them seem to keep introducing
themselves it's like it works a time or
two if you see a personality that almost
never has the light but half the time
I'm like it's clear that he oscillate
Sal OTT and you're all in this facility
together I know it's only a three day
window but like why are why are you all
introducing time when you're not seeing
very many different people and you're
not going to very many different this is
you know like in the in huh and speaking
of illogical things I just so stupid the
way that whole hospital was run when
Sarah Paulsen's like to tell Anya Taylor
joy know you can't see him you're the
victim next shot okay I'm gonna put you
directly in front of this guy and I'm
gonna let you hug him and stop no this
is so dumb that's what I mean I think
now one part of this sold me on who she
worked the audience is supposed to
believe she is not one part of me cuz
I'm like she's she makes dumb calls all
the time see that moment weirdly enough
that that moment
in an odd way because I thought Sarah
Paulsen's said the wrong thing and
realized it and then and then she took
her to see him because it's like you
you're the victim it should be up to you
is is like the ultimate point so she
says it's completely the wrong things
just like no you can't you're the victim
and then they go and I'm like oh well
maybe there's some kind of deleted
moment or so maybe like or war she
realizes like well why am I telling you
what you should be doing you know well
okay I'll meet you halfway there if the
movie doesn't earn it anya taylor joy
was sitting behind the lights not as
clear as we are in proximity at this
very moment like how come none of the
orderly can get this close to james
mcavoy but the woman he [ __ ]
kidnapped can makes no sense to me
first i thought she wanted to talk to
David Dunn honestly and that's you know
I was confused I was like Oh Kevin
Wright I didn't like the moments that
had me going were when glassing Kevin
we're teaming up like one one nugget I
really appreciated was that glass always
talked to one of the personalities as if
they were actual individual people it
was never like let me play along or I'm
judging you or he just always talked to
each individual like they were some like
they were a different person it tries to
kind of find out who each of them is
yeah well like later nine forever right
when head when Hedwig was like I want to
dance you know that thing I love that
literally is for a movie called glass
it's a good thing the best part of this
movie is Sam Jackson simultaneously it's
kind of not really a good chunk of like
the first half earned that - yeah no but
ultimately it's just like oh good he's
here it feels like a finally very edited
down movie to meet a runtime it really
felt that way like Barry edited down I
would I actually wouldn't be surprised
that they released some three-hour cut
that I loved I will not be surprised
yeah cuz I'm like there's a lot here
that I just feel like is not explored I
hate that they diminish David Dunn I
hate that when he's the hero and for a
movie that preaches so much about comic
book world and lore you just seem to
completely neglect the [ __ ] hero
department here and then you just kill
him off so you could have a twist reveal
and then and also with the Shamrock
people I hate what I guess what I hate
about the final moment with the three of
them sitting around at the train station
the idea of Sam Jackson releasing the
footage to the public is fine by me I
hate that those three are together like
they're a [ __ ] family united now
because they're all honoring glasses you
know intentions and dreams and vision if
it was if there was a rewrite on that
moment for me of they're there because
people need to know about the hero that
was David John if that was like uh like
talked about motivation I could have
been on board for that but instead like
for me I'm like Shamrock people don't
seem like bad guys to me yeah I don't
agree they kill like killing David Dunn
is a [ __ ] up move but really they got
rid of two terrible people they got rid
of a met a serial killer and a mass
murderer yeah so 200 the three aren't
bad feet are like bad people who should
have been rid of it so I thought they're
actually doing a good deed if these
[ __ ] people with superpowers
primarily come in the form of terrible
people you should probably get rid of
them
and David Dunn was an exception and
that's a heartbreaking thing but it
doesn't earn his death and so I'm like I
don't really view shamrock people as the
terrible people here yet this movie kind
of glorifies the ambitions of glass and
Kevin as things that need to be shown to
the world in this beautiful way and
let's have if victim girl goes mass
murderers mom and the son of the actual
hero all like holding hands together at
the train station and it just it felt
like your message is getting lost and
you're diminishing the characters now
for your point I like the idea that they
would all three wind up together somehow
because they it would make sense for
them to be bonded by all this
but yeah just what they're there for
yeah as this movie puts it is just kind
of like to see them all together
kind of sweep of what's going on
underneath it is haunted by drizzle yeah
there's just too much the problem is for
me overall this movie wants to play in a
lot of gray territory which I appreciate
it for wanting to do but the problem is
you got to really be on your A game you
got to be organized you got to know the
points you want to make you got to know
what your subject you got and really
have a good grip on the gray because if
you don't it becomes this muddy mess of
like wait what are the motivations it
seems like these characters are
forgetting about whole aspects of these
people you know it's like these are all
challenging characters in a plot that
doesn't really know how to handle how
challenging they all can be and so the
nuances are always stunted for the most
part because of that and the things that
work are just quiet moments in between
yes part I just I didn't like that it
takes this shift for the kind of
portrays glass and and Kevin as
something that is this beautiful thing
that needs to be shown to the world now
I get the the the the unity of the three
of them of this like beautiful but
twisted just yeah there there's horrible
stuff about it but these people exist
there are other people like them the
world deserves to know about that
but yeah I don't know the the way we had
we had a difference of opinion on
because I was like it seemed like what
he really wanted to get out there was
that people like this existed which
ultimately made me feel like David Dunn
feels more unnecessary like this is my
opinion that David Dunn feels more
necessary because of the fact that when
you see all that footage at the end all
you really see if David doing is bending
a [ __ ] bar but you see like Kevin
Joyce you know flipping over cars with
people in them and hopping across the
grass like a [ __ ] animal like doing
crazy ass [ __ ] so I'm like if the point
is to show patently people someone else
down the door and things like that
inside when he breaks out yeah but I'm
like Kevin could do all that no no David
yeah I'm saying Kevin could do all that
so there's David even necessary but you
had a thing about wolf throat for Elijah
I feel like it comes back to the comic
book thing is I don't necessary
we think that his master plan is to
massacre a bunch of people again I think
to get his point across he I think it
hurts this point if he only shows the
world a horrifying villain he needs the
hero sight of that to show the Union
Yang so that it gets the point across
better than just oh [ __ ] monster kill it
it's sort of like oh damn like yeah
destruction happened but that's an issue
but also there's this super-powered guy
fighting against the bad super-powered
guy and that brings the whole picture to
me but but I see here's my problem with
that
like I I'm off I'm actually like way
onboard for what you're talking about
the thing is I'm like well what I'm
looking at the footage though oh yeah
like what I'm seeing is a guy who's
breaking out of a [ __ ] he's a patient
who's breaking out and is beating up a
bunch of cops and then throws them in
something and seals them in there it
does like all this all the little
nuances of him saying I'm doing this to
protect you to the cops that one time
David says it like that being picked up
on the audio here like hoover's to me
I'm like this footage actually makes it
look like David is a villain just
because he's fighting Kevin does that
he's also showing he's harming police
officers he's breaking out of places he
looks like a threat no he has a
reputation though I mean people know
that the overseer they also probably
know who the Horde is because there's
word around town David's tracking him
that's fair no I'll give you that I'm
just saying that the footage itself when
already the overseer is has a reputation
but he's also portrayed as a vigilante
who is doing illegal crimes and it
shouldn't be doing that's what I mean
it's like there's this [ __ ] debate
about is he a good guy like in the
public sphere
yeah which is yeah this is perhaps the
most familiar debate this movie goes for
is just vigilantism good or bad in which
we've seen a thousand times before this
is the part of the spoiler review
podcast where Gregg interrupts it
because he's in control the editing
system right now I was talking with JT
from screen junkies last night and he
reminded me of a couple of things that
really bothered me that you pointed out
like oh yeah so I forgot to mention that
and I figured everybody come this far
with Dagon on the film might as well
just keep going a little bit further
when David Dunn dies I'm all for the
idea that he dies in this movie like I
said in this review already but the fact
that he dies by some dude holding his
face down in the little puddle of water
and if he was like completely underwater
submerged in or something the tank even
that would be another thing but no one
on the Shamrock team should have
superpowers I know what you'd have
super-strength or else that goes against
the little Shamrock team idea
so obviously can't David just knock this
guy's hand away or push himself up or
something it just it seemed like just a
cheap way for him to go out but the way
this movie sometimes treats him with how
water is his weakness just makes me
start questioning like can this guy
shower you know the water gets his faces
he's just weak well why has it treated
this way and GT he was also talking
about how James MacAvoy not James man
but Chris Stockman was saying to James
McAvoy with the lights that flashed and
keep him from leaving the room that he
could have like put a pillow on his face
or closed his eyes or ran past the
lights or something to avoid the block
yeah that's a good point
and the other thing that really annoyed
me that I didn't touch her on this
review that JT was reminding me of was
that when Joseph Dunn interrupts the
fight to happily explain the plot just
reveal about how glass is responsible
for the death of Kevin's dad that moment
I thought was so poorly and so corny is
not executed well I like the idea that
he figures that out this was one thing
but the way he lays it out because one
of the things that I'm hearing a lot of
people especially on the Twittersphere
say is how some people just they really
just want their big superhero action
films and they just can't understand a
more nuanced story and like that's not
it at all I think it's way overly
explained and I completely understand
everything that's going on I just don't
I just think the way it's handled is
not up to par with stuff like
unbreakable or split anyway I come this
far I might as well dig that hole a
little deeper back to the the regular
film podcast that's the biggest
heartbreaker about this movie as I feel
like it has a lot of interesting ideas
about superheroes and comic books and
and stuff that it would be worthwhile
especially now that that type of
entertainment is king like yeah bring
back an unbreakable type thing that
deconstructs the the subject matter
while also bringing us a new take on it
that's more cinematic that's more you
know authored by one specific the thing
is I do disagree that this movie doesn't
have a tone it's a mess but it has a
very distinct tone to me it feels like
nobody else could have directed this
movie but Shyamalan like I it has his
visual and pacing earmarks all over it
for as inexplicably messy as it is I
feel like that all serves to just
strengthen the identity of this movie in
a weird way as a mess but as a very
distinct mess because I think this
movie's gonna stick with me even if it
doesn't in a good way I'm not gonna
forget her like I'm not gonna forget the
choices that tried to make and I feel I
so many things about it because it did
so many distinct things where I was like
what is happening I felt like it didn't
find its own unique voice though its own
unique tone it really it didn't ever
find clarity I felt like that it's it's
tone was it's messy because I felt like
its tone was shifting between wanting to
be the split tone or the unbreakable
tone and it never felt like it quite met
yeah it didn't it didn't manage to
coalesce them but well maybe for me
intermittently like there were times
when I quite liked the horror angles or
the more unbreakable angles or I don't
know just some of the choices in super
in a minute for for me personally yes
it's super in a minute yeah like I said
earlier on it that it was the whole
movie I was being pulled in and pulled
out and there are some scenes that I
think sing pretty well and there are
other scenes that are just mad flat and
needed a different approach or different
tone or some other idea or whatever but
well like I said the very beginning
there's several ways you can rank this
movie and but for me personally as a fan
of a huge fan of unbreakable a guy who
really admires split I felt like it
really did not
ultimately serve up to that as its own
movie it's very very intermittent for
like it's a fine January movie but it's
very intermittent for me it sort of like
it's down like there's so many so many
questionable plot whole things to me
that are just and like terribly written
dialogue throughout and lack of focus
that I just I altum Utley makes for a
not good movie for me were where I think
that yeah not like yeah that's my
overall feeling III was very much let
down by this movie you know I was I was
like let down and fascinated is this is
one of those movies that strikes me that
way cuz I can feel so many things that
might have happened and I like the
concept of what this movie is I just
don't like the physical of what this
movie is and so it ultimately just made
me more bummed than angry you know now
cuz I was like this was our concern that
we would talk about off-camera what we
heard about glass was like he's kind of
rushing into this see I would be angry
if it just didn't try know this movie
surprise way bad things way to all
that's why early on in this talk I gave
it credit for not being boring yeah I
would be mad if Shyamalan checked out
and gave us like just yes straight
[ __ ] where it's clear he didn't
really when I saw the review capsule I'm
like oh god is gonna be another
slow-moving boring a shot I was actually
concerned gonna be like [ __ ] doubling
down on that goddamn slow-paced [ __ ]
that he knows and I'm like oh wow it's
actually the antithesis this is so
fast-paced like it it moves at a like
especially in the first act is for that
it rapidly moves it starts to slow down
at the asylum but then it explores
things that ultimately I didn't find
that all that fulfilling weirdly as much
as I hate that [ __ ] pun to
glass-half-full [ __ ] like agree with
them like yeah it feels like a lot of
its intent is really met only halfway a
lot of concept all it needed was more
poignant character moments a deeper
subtext you know a sadder meta justice
done to that particular character
a more finessed way of reducing the
shadowy organization like as a fan that
I think that's why as death his death
more than anyone else has upset me the
most because I'm like you kind of check
out that he's in this movie then you
just sort of kill him off it should be a
huge moment it should be a recording all
right especially for a comic-book talk
the movie I don't know the problem is
the way they all the the physical of how
they all each die I feel like maybe
could have worked in a better movie as
it stands just as a movie goer I I would
have hoped for a truly great ending
moment for David Dunne as it stands
though like this weird you know humanity
and reality and stuff I get the stark
kind of sadness of how it ends I just
don't think it serves this movie overall
no duh yeah that's a great way to put it
and and yeah I mean I like that Kevin
ultimately is the way that he's gonna
kills class right like ultimately he
dies because yeah he yeah I like that
moment and I like his breakdown woman I
don't agree that he makes superheroes
I'm like well Dave laughs I'm like David
was born that way you just help them
learn that and Kevin never got treated
it killed like a thousand people never
found out how to deal with the really
you got like a terrible law of averages
yeah but I like his breakdown moment
we're like oh [ __ ] that's evil
mastermind glass like I like that moment
he's the best part he is yeah all right
guys well I got a doctor's a party to
right now what did you think of glass
you mad that I ranted on it for you know
I I tried all I could do was express my
opinion and that's how I felt
yeah I know there there are people who
love this movie and if you do good for
you I and I'm said I'm excited to talk
about it because I think it's cool that
you right now you have three different
spectrums I'm seeing in terms of how
people feel about this movie you have
people who are like what the weird
creaks talking about I love this movie
then there are people who go two-thirds
of it are good the fanatics
a letdown and then you got people we
fall in the spectrum over BAM what a
disappointment
yeah so you got three pretty much
different opinions and those tend to be
the three and I'm on that side I think
this takes the cake as his most divisive
movie and that's cool yeah cuz in at
least we got an actual film to debate
and talk about you last Jedi has arrived
I would much rather this then than
something just like even though I kind
of get the happening a little better now
I would much rather this than a
happening or than a later or something
like that well you guys can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification bell and check us on
patreon got a lot of goodies there I'll
talk to you guys soon